[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti à pour le
sommaire football hardricourt a créé la
surprise l'équipe 2 de la commissaire
imposé sur la pelouse de verneuil lors
de la 19e journée de deuxième division
de district score final à 5 à 2 le
résumé dans ce magazine
insolite le jeune thomas d'eric guidon
et venir ici en plateau a tenté un pari
fou cette ligne montrent un de 20 ans a
décidé de traversée de désert en bolivie
à pied en solitaire en totale autonomie
son gps nous le recevrons dans ce
magazine football encore avec la coupe
du monde féminine le site de croissy sur
seine a été retenue pour accueillir
quatre équipes nationales à partir du 3
juin dans l'équipe de france et l'équipe
des états unis
plus d'informations à suivre l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
on commence tout de suite par du
football et le championnat de 2e
division de district verneuil recevait
l'équipe 2 d'hardricourt ce week-end et
les locaux se sont fait surprendre sur
leur terrain le score est sans appel à 5
à 2 des images de mélanie poker montage
de xavier jama a brick pour créer la
surprise l'équipe 2 de la commune qui
jouent en loire s'est imposé sur la
pelouse de verneuil lors de la 19e
journée de deuxième division de district
après avoir mené 2 0 les visiteurs se
font rejoindre à deux partout sur ce
penalty les ardres et courtois
profiteront des espaces en fin de match
pour marquer trois buts score final 5 à
2 les gars ont respecté les consignes ce
n'était pas un match facile on
s'attendait on savait qu'on allait avoir
une opposition difficile face à verneuil
qui jouait le haut du tableau mais dans
l'ensemble on voit là les gars ont sorti
le match qu'il fallait quand il fallait
on a manqué un peu de réalisme après ils
ont su nous contrer ils ont été
efficaces
du coup mené 2-0 à la mi-temps donc
difficile mais voilà on a essayé de
pousser ça n'a pas marché
après ce match vernet pointe à la
troisième place du classement à deux
journées de la fin du championnat
son côté hardricourt en difficulté
depuis le début de la saison respire
l'équipe est désormais 9e et s'éloigne
de la zone de relégation
le maintien normalement ulation
aujourd'hui mais bon il nous reste
encore deux matches à jouer on va les
jouer à fond pour essayer de gagner une
ou deux places encore sur des matches
comme ça voilà ça fait plaisir et on
pense qu'on va pouvoir se sauver
c'est le principal prochain match pour
les deux équipes le dimanche 19 mai vers
nice se déplacera sur le terrain de vale
78 et hardricourt recevra sur sa pelouse
le club de billy si on continue à parler
de football dans le championnat de
première division de district mort passe
est incliné 2 1 sur la pelouse de
marly-le-roi équipe une d'hardricourt
n'a pu faire mieux que 1 partout face
aux chaînés match nul également entre
sartrouville et carrière grésillons 2
partout le fc mantois n'a pas fait de
détail face à guyancourt le score 3 à 0
carton également pour gargenville face à
plaisir 4 buts à 1 enfin où il s'impose
contre montesson 3-2 de championnat et
toujours dominé par marly le roi qui a
six points d'avancé sur le second
toujours en football mais cette fois ci
dans le championnat de national troyes
versailles remonte au classement les
hommes de la cité royale se sont imposés
3 2 à l'extérieur sur le terrain de b
revillier résultat qui leur permet
d'espérer un podium en fin de saison ils
sont actuellement troisièmes
24 matches disputés à quatre unités du
premier les gobelins la fin de saison
s'annonce palpitante du baseball à
présent les cougars joué la semaine
dernière le challenge de france à
montpellier
l'un des plus gros tournois français
après avoir remporté le premier match
contre le puc de paris 11 à 1
les il monta en connu un vendredi
contrastée entre une défaite contre les
templiers de sénart une victoire contre
les boucaniers de la rochelle se sont
finalement inclinés le samedi contre
auront une défaite qui leur a refermé
les portes de la finale une semaine
plutôt positif pour les cougars qui
s'était présenté avec une équipe
diminuée on écoute l'entraîneur de
l'équipe
rodolphe le meur a réussi à les
accrocher quand même les deux équipes
qui se retrouvent en finale malgré une
équipe diminuée mais voilà c'est quand
même plus de ce qui ce nom et à ses
aspirations pour pour les cobras parce
que c'était quand même des cépages et à
se partager les challenges c'est un
format de qui ressemble un peu à la
coupe d'europe c'était quelque chose qui
qu'on attendait pour pouvoir vraiment
savoir si l'équipe était prête coupe
d'europe se déroulera du 5 au 9 juin en
république tchèque en football américain
la rencontre entre les templiers
d'elancourt et les diables rouges de
villepin n'a pas pu se tenir programmé
ce samedi soir au complexe sportif
europe la rencontre a dû être annulée à
cause d'un point du règlement le médecin
qui devait encadrer la rencontre a pu
faire venir n'a pu venir et aucune
solution de remplacement n'a pu être
trouvée dans le temps imparti les
arbitres ont donc dû annuler la
rencontre le match pourrait être perdus
sur tapis vert la décision sera prise
par la commission fédérale
autre annulation ce week-end la 84e
édition de la run and bike de maurepas
le rendez vous qui devait regrouper
plusieurs centaines de sportifs a dû
être annulé à cause des intempéries
de la grêle s'est abattu sur la commune
pendant l'après-midi par précaution les
organisateurs ont préféré annuler pour
garantir la sécurité des participants
on ouvre une page handball chez les
féminines montigny le bretonneux respire
enfin après plusieurs résultats négatifs
lésigny monthey n'a réussi à s'imposer
dans le gymnase de lisieux samedi soir
le score est sans appel 42 à 30 2 avec
cette victoire le club remonte à la
huitième place après 20 journées à
disputer
on continue à parler de handball mais
cette fois ci un masculin plaisir n'y
arrive toujours pas l'équipe a concédé
un deuxième match nul consécutif face à
haguenau le score 28 partout résultat
qui n'arrange pas les affaires des
plaisirs
qu'ils restent dixièmes sur 12 l'équipe
est toujours sous la menace d'une
relégation en fin de saison on prend
maintenant la direction de sartrouville
c'était une grande première pour la
ville les phases finales de la coupe de
france des moins de 13 ans de volley
ball étaient organisées pendant trois
jours dans deux gymnases de la commune
au total douze équipes venues de toute
la france ont participé à ce rendez vous
dont des clubs du sud comme cannes
l'équipe locale sartrouville et est
également représentée en écoute la
réaction du président claude michel au
micro de tv 78 la coupe de france et le
championnat de france par excellence au
niveau des jeunes et donc ça nous permet
de re travers de cette de cette
compétition à la fois de montrer notre
savoir faire et puis de participer à un
événement national
le niveau est ce qui se fait de mieux en
france les modèles de cette catégorie
d'âge
nous avons dans parmi les jeunes qui
sont là des futurs cadres de l'équipe de
france
le tournoi a été remporté par rhône
ouvèze face à montpellier sartrouville
termine avant derniers de ce rendez vous
il y aura un autre un rendez vous
insolite ce week-end un open national de
savate forme un sport qui mélange la
boxe et le fitness est organisée ce
samedi à partir de 13h30 au palais des
sports d'el en cours pour nous parler de
ce rendez-vous nous recevrons sur ce
plateau alexandre foucher président de
l'école de boxe française et l'encours
maurepas c'est une pratiquante coralie
cheveux bonsoir alors pouvez vous nous
présenter ce sport cette discipline qui
n'est pas forcément connus du grand
public
c'est une discipline très intéressante
parce qu'elle regroupe
la technique de la boxe française avec
un vous l'avez dit du cardio et des
fitness c'est très très complet parce
que ça nous permet vraiment dans fait de
voile a travaillé toute la technique
qu'on voit en boxe française à la
perfection mais tout en mettant dans la
musique dans une ambiance très agréable
et elle nous permet aussi justement de
pratiquer la boxe française sans pour
autant aimé les combats ou les sports
comme ça où on peut se prendre des coups
donc c'est vraiment complémentaires
c'est très intéressant et c'est confirmé
oui enfin en tout cas moi en tant que
moniteur je cherche à faire en sorte que
tout le monde se plaît que l'on s'amuse
au maximum et effectivement d'un point
de vue sportif c'est regroupe toutes les
techniques boss est donc c'est pour ça
que c'est complémentaire on fait
beaucoup d'étirements
on doit donner des coups de pied à la
tête quand on peut on travaille
énormément et puis il faut imaginer un
cours d'une heure et demie pendant
lesquelles vous allez faire que ce
ticket et vous battre et quels sont les
bienfaits justement de cette discipline
alors éventuellement s'user manger trop
jour le trop lourd le midi vous allez
bien digérer ça c'est clair ça cet effet
là après des bienfaits les points de vue
de la santé
c'est un sport comme le fitness donc
c'est très très bon tu disais coralie
pour le coeur musculairement d'un point
de vue étirements et autres mais je
pense que
c'est surtout le moral en effet c'est
vrai que quand on pratique cette
discipline
on se concentre vraiment pour apprendre
la chorégraphie bien faire notre
technique ce qui nous permet vraiment de
évacuer tout ce qu'on a vécu durant la
journée est vraiment que penser à cette
chorégraphie qu'on a à faire et à cette
technique qu'on doit avoir c'est
notamment vraiment d'évacuer voilà tout
le stress tout ce qu'on a pu ressentir
on est vraiment focalisé par une
araignée sur ce qu'on fait et ce qu'on
pratique il faut en faire vraiment
régulièrement pour progresser oui bien
sûr pour avoir la technique qu'il faut
le faire régulièrement
c'est vrai qu'on a la chance d'avoir un
club qui nous propose de faire 1h30 de
lundi une heure et demie de vendredi ça
fait quand même pas mal sur une semaine
à prendre aussi la possibilité de faire
de la boxe en plus donc ça nous permet
vraiment de progresser rapidement
il ya beaucoup de pratiquants en france
alors oui aujourd'hui en france vous
avez sur à peu près 50 à 60 mille
adhérents de la boxe française y en a à
peu près 10 15 milles sur une immeubles
sur sur la savate forme de là aussi dans
ce type de compétition ou d'une réunion
de stage qu'on a cette forme on
accueille aussi on rencontre aussi les
gens qui font du cardio boxing ou dix
combats et c'est avec effectivement
cette particularité da savate forme que
pour être moniteur de savate forme il
faut avoir fait de la boxe
contrairement au body combat où souvent
on peut avoir un bon niveau de fitness
est professeur de body combat là cette
particularité a pour but effective que
l'on fasse des techniques de boxe réel
et qu'on apprenne vraiment cet
univers-là donc oui il ya beaucoup
d'adhérents nous dans notre club nous
sommes un club à un peu plus de 140
adhérents et plus de la moitié font delà
de la savate forme et ça attire vraiment
un nouveau public
ça attire complètement un nouveau public
un nouveau public qui est extrêmement
féminin puisque avant d'ouvrir une
session savate forme
nous avions à peu près 15 % de féminines
dans notre club depuis que l'eau vers la
savate forme on a une majorité de
féminines sûr qu'on est à peu près
presque aux deux tiers
de plus luc féminin grâce à la savate
forme et c'est souvent cette discipline
qui fait le pont et qui permet à
certaines tireuse de savate forme de
passer tireuse boxe française de rentrer
dans cet univers de la boxe française et
comme corps coralie est ce que vous
auriez pu vous vous lancez dans la boxe
française
alors j'ai essayé j'ai fait un an de
boxe française avant de me lancer dans
la savate forme mais la savate forme a
vraiment fait permis de développer voilà
une technique en que je n'avais pas faim
la maison ce que je n'avais pas en boxe
française et c'est vrai que depuis que
j'ai fait sa ba je me sens beaucoup plus
à l'aise dans les techniques de boxe et
du coup a pratiqué dans les combats ça
fait combien de temps que vous avez créé
cette section au sein du club on la crée
en 2014 au sein du club au sein du club
elle encourt maurepas auparavant
j'enseignais au club de bois d'arcy qui
avait créé cette session 4 ans à peu
près avant est ce que je peux dire c'est
que c'est un petit peu à la mode alors
il ya un effet il ya un effet de mode
évident qui vient du fait qu'aujourd'hui
on cherche à mieux maîtriser son corps à
mieux le connaître mieux l'écouter et
c'est vrai que du coup on va souvent
salins fait souvent du fitness et là on
a tous et toutes ses activités réunit à
la fois du stretching à la fois du
cardio à la fois du step à la fois aussi
des techniques même de déplacement et et
de mouvement donc oui il ya un effet de
mode mais qui n'est pas un effet de mode
de la savate forme qui a un défi qui est
moins gérer un effet de mode au sens où
c'est moins temporaire que le fait que
c'est une nouvelle volonté aujourd'hui
que l'on a d'être heureux en se sentant
bien dans son corps et ce type
d'activité qui nous permet aujourd'hui
effectivement de se sentir demain mieux
dans son corps même deux jours et vous
coralie qu'est ce qui vous a incité
pourra participer pour première fois un
cours c'est quelqu'un qui vous en a
parlé
alors en fait on a eu beaucoup même non
pas du tout en fait on a connu
l'association par mon petit frère qui a
voulu commencer la boxe française puis
on m'a proposé voilà il m'a proposé de
venir faire un essai donc j'ai essayé et
anne ont justement après j'avais
pratiqué la boxe française ma mère qui
pratiquait la savate forme madiba bien
essayé franchement ça va te plaire tu
vas voir c'est plein de technique comme
tu aimes et c'est vrai que je souhaitais
pas le côté vraiment cardio avec de la
musique le côté entraînant de la chose
était vraiment très intéressante et les
adhérents qui alors on va revenir sur
sur l'événement qui va se dérouler ce
week-end à elancourt pourquoi
l'organisait il encourt alors ça faisait
plus de dix ans que cet événement
national qui est le grand regroupement
des clubs de savate forme de france
faisait plus de dix ans que cet
événement n'avait plus lieu en ile de
france et donc en fait on a proposé des
jalles et depuis l'année dernière notre
candidature pour que cet événement qui
fait le tour de france qui tous les ans
change change de lieu les dernières
étaient à bordeaux l'année précédente
a marseille je crois sous retour dans
l'île de france et ça nous permet de de
dirt fédérer l'ensemble des clubs
l'ile-de-france du nord de toutes les
régions ça l'intérêt d'être centre a
décentralisé dans soixante dix huit pour
effectivement accueillir rencontrer les
autres clubs et dans ce contexte de
compétition bat surtout faire des stages
ensemble se partager les techniques
partager les nouveautés les nouveaux
styles qui peuvent apparaître et donc
fédérer fédérer ce club et aussi on
espère amener le maximum de personnes à
découvrir cette discipline et c'est
vraiment une première année en cours
c'est la première à elancourt je crois
même que c'est la première dans le 78
qu'on ait pu organiser cette compétition
qui repartira qui repartira jédir à
l'étranger mais c'est pas gentil qui
repartira en province l'année prochaine
coralie vous avez participé à la
compétition
tout à fait je fais partie d'une des
membres de
de l'équipe de savate forme donc voilà
c'est vraiment pour nous un gros
challenge mais ça nous motive aussi à
progresser d'autant plus et on espère
que ça va se passer du mieux possible
dans une bonne ambiance vraiment qu'il y
aura plein de monde pour venir voir ce
qu'on fait puis c'est pas c'est même
comme il a dit ça nous permet de voir
aussi d'autres techniques parce que d'un
professeur à l'autre c'est vrai que les
techniques changent la façon de faire
des chorégraphies changé c'est très
intéressant de pouvoir faire justement
une rencontre sportive et de voir son
club voilà tout à fait comment ça va se
dérouler concrètement cette compétition
alors pour les spectateurs ça va se
dérouler à partir de 13h30 les équipes
vont commencer à s'échauffer ensemble et
ensuite chaque équipe
chaque équipe doit montrer la
chorégraphie qu'est la preuve qu'elle a
préparé pendant l'année il y à deux
niveaux un niveau c'est rien série de en
fonction d'une disponibilité concave et
ses équipes en gros c'est une des
équipes qui seront plus professionnel
qu'ont pu vraiment s'investir et
d'autres qui sont venus pour participer
on appellera ses séries 2 ils vont
montrer une chorégraphie à peu près deux
minutes trente trois minutes où ils vous
ont pour objectif de montrer toutes les
techniques de savate boxe française qui
existent tout ça en musique en rythme et
tout le monde chorégraphié bien ensemble
ça c'est le déroulé du samedi qui va se
terminer par un stage et la remise des
récompenses stages ouverts au public
s'ils veulent s'initier à cette occasion
à savate forme ce que l'on a voulu
c'était aussi pouvoir faire profiter
l'ensemble des équipes de france du 78
et se dire voilà vous fait le voyage à
10 parfois en minibus pour faire des
économies et venir venir de lyon venir
damien venir du doigt deux doigts pour
pouvoir faire cette compétition alors on
vous accueille et donc on va les
accueillir tous les week-ends après
cette compétition on ira dans les
restaurants de la région
on sort on s'est organisé pour pouvoir
dormir le tous ensemble et demain et le
dimanche et je suis déjà et dimanche on
a proposé un certain nombre d'activités
donc la boxe française évidemment de la
canne de combat refaire la savate forme
pour ce qu'ils veulent mais aussi des
activités plus détente et plus
culturelle comme aller visiter le
château de versailles comme
la france miniature où nous profiter
aussi des spas de la région donc ça a
permis de dire aux équipes voilà vous
venez de loin
vous avez fait cet effort alors on peut
vous accueillir et vous permettre de
profiter du soixante dix huit pour pour
passer un excellent week-end tous
ensemble en 10 secondes
coralie est ce que vous pouvez nous
donner envie de venir à cet open tout
simplement venez découvrir voilà une
ambiance sportive agréable avec plein de
compétiteurs venus de toute la france
c'est vraiment très très intéressant et
c'est que du bonheur de faire ça en
équipe
il ya une grande cohésion groupe merci à
tous les deux dépassé sur ce plateau où
vous souhaite bon courage pour
l'organisation de cet événement pour
rappel l'open national de savate forme
est organisée ce samedi à 18 mai à
partir de 13 heures 30 au palais des
sports d'el en cours en basket le
chesnay-versailles jouer ce week-end les
quarts de finale de playoffs de
prénationale et l'équipe est toujours en
course pour la montée en fin de saison
les yvelinois se sont imposés chez le
basket paris 14 sur le score de 73 à 52
et prennent une sérieuse option avant de
disputer le match retour samedi prochain
les joueurs ne veulent pas entendre
parler de remonta dans l' écoute bamba
cei
l'un des joueurs de l'équipe de
l'entente le chesnay versailles après
nous allons maintenant prendre le large
dans cette émission le départ de la
prochaine transat jacques vabre est
programmée le 27 27 octobre depuis le
havre
oui personne originaire de rambouillet
participera cette course à bord de son
imoca bureau vallée 2 pour cette
aventure le skipper sera accompagné de
son ami d'avis à boda un sportif pour
tourner 33 ans
leur objectif rejoindre le port de
salvador de bahia le plus rapidement
possible pour cela louis burton compte
sur son ami de longue date
on a toujours été très proche a fait du
bateau sombre et caetera et puis après
on a aussi été très proches dans la vie
perso donc
il a fait beaucoup de villes il a tout
gagné en libye capturez les compétences
en sur l'eau comme ça en fait
et puisqu'une bonne entente
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
on commence par du football la coupe du
monde féminine commence le 7 juin et les
yvelines vont participer à cette grande
fête
la fifa le comité d'organisation retenu
croissy-sur-seine comme terrain
d'entraînement pour quatre équipes
nationales dont l'équipe de france et la
dream team américaine à montage de
romain respini les stars du football
vont à nouveau fouler cette pelouse deux
ans après l'euro 2016 et la venue de
l'équipe de russie croissy-sur-seine
sera la seule ville évinoise accueillir
des sessions d'entraînement des équipes
nationales pour la coupe du monde
féminine
une décision prise en avril dernier par
la fifa et le comité d'organisation
c'est une surprise non c'est la
continuation de ce qu'on avait déjà
engagé avec l'euro 2016 et puis l'équipe
d'angleterre l'année d'après qui est
venu s'entraîner ici
donc effectivement on avait candidaté
pour la coupe du monde au total quatre
équipes nationales vont s'entraîner sur
le site à partir du 3 juin l'afrique du
sud l'ecosse et surtout la dream team
américaine trois fois vainqueur de
l'édition est tenant du titre
les supporters pourront également voir
un entraînement de l'équipe de france
hôte de la compétition l'équipe de
france est première numéro un mondial
l'équipe des états unis oui ça peut me
convenir bien sûr escale intéressant
c'est qu'il y aura des entraînements
ouverts
donc on pourra faire profiter nos jeunes
sportifs ils pourront côtoyer des
sportifs de haut niveau et ça c'est
aussi très important pour moi je pense
qu'on n'a pas de faire monter la sauce
elles montrent déjà rien que de savoir
que les ya un seul entraînement ouvert
pour l'équipe de france et qui se
passera à croissy on aura là du monde
largement autant qu'on en veut
comme pour l'euro 2016 les équipes
évolueront principalement sur le terrain
d'honneur pendant les sessions
d'entraînement dans le gymnase on
retrouvera les vestiaires ainsi qu'une
salle de fitness pour travailler le
renforcement musculaire
un espace sera également dédié à la
presse les aménagements tout effet type
euro 2016 donc a pas de différence si ce
n'est un stade qui est un petit peu plus
large que celui de l'euro 2016 pour
promouvoir dans la ville le football
féminin et cette huitième coupe du monde
des animations seront organisées dans la
ville de croissy sur seine avec
notamment la mise en place d'une fan
zone derrière le terrain d'entraînement
pour suivre les matchs jusqu'au 7
juillet
et on termine par du golfe si vous avez
envie de tester votre swing et des
initiations gratuites sont proposées
jusqu'au 16 juin dans les golfs du
réseau blue green dont celui de saint
quentin en yvelines
au programme deux heures de pratique
pour les familles avec des
professionnels proposeront de taper la
balle sur les practice ou de travailler
votre petit jeu pour participer il faut
vous inscrire sur le site internet du
golfe 1 7 8 sport plus court qu'à
l'accoutumée le jeune thomas à derrick 7
il monte un de 20 ans qui a décidé de
traverser à 2 des heures en bolivie à
pied en solitaire en totale autonomie et
sans gps n'a pas pu venir sur ce plateau
on tentera de l'avoir dans une prochaine
émission
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]